hi there uh this is steve kaufman here
and uh i've been asked to do a video on
how i use
link for check so here is my sort of
landing page when i come to my
link
um
area here
and uh you'll see that i have lessons i
can go check up on my friends there's a
forum
there's a within lessons there's a
library
and here are the lessons that i have
been working on most recently
now
in so far the first thing i want to talk
about is is where we get our content
from
and
when i first began doing check i relied
very much on our library
so if i go to my library i can see that
you know in intermediate there's a whole
bunch of lessons there i can also go to
beginner and i'll see some lessons and
most of these have been created for us
by our members
and we've had good response from uh
czech native speakers in terms of them
creating beginner lessons and
intermediate lessons
but i'm now past that so in fact i don't
rely
on our library anymore i bringing bring
in content from elsewhere on the web so
i'll show you how i do that
i typically go to radio praha here which
i have as an icon
and
i look for those uh items
that have a um
you know have a sound file attached to
them
and so uh you know i could choose this
one here for example
uh
and open it up
and i find there's an audio file so i
right click on that and save the link as
so that is now saved into my computer
and then what i try to do is uh save
this
here
i go and and copy it
like so and
copy
and then
i go to a
link
here
and i go to an area under lessons which
is called import
and
import opens up and you'll see that i
have a lot of stuff saved under radio
prog so i'm going to add this to this
will be my 31st
i have radio prog 1 radio product 2. i'm
up to about 60 lessons here in radio
prague
and i add this lesson
now i'm soon going to create a new
collection
called a radio prog
3
so here i take this title
and i put it up here
and the other thing i like to do is i
like to get rid of
anything that you know pictures and
stuff that really are only going to mess
up my text
because uh pictures will not show up
in the article as it appears
in uh anyway you get the picture here i
don't know if i need to do them all but
that kind of cleans it up and then i go
to look for the sound file that i just
downloaded and i put that there
and then i save it okay so now that
article
is saving into into link
now uh
the other source that i have for uh
let's go back to here is the radio praha
site
i can also import um from a newspaper so
i go here to chesky nobody
and go in there and see what they've got
i
close that oh that looks kind of nice
what i do is i
open that
and um
and then i pick an area that i want to
save
such as this
and uh
there and then i go to what's called a
bookmarklet i click on the bookmarklet
confirm that this is indeed check
and import it
now that brings that lesson into link so
now i have two lessons that i have
loaded into link
uh
this is the
the one that i just brought in which is
the newspaper one and you'll notice that
there are no sound files attached to it
because it's just a newspaper article so
i'm going to in a separate video i'll
show you how i actually work these texts
but i'm going to focus
on this first video on how i how i find
content
so there's that one
and
the one that
the one that we
brought in earlier from the radio
station
is now sitting in my
uh
my lessons area in fact we can see the
two of them here we see the radio praha
one
and we see right away that it has 21 new
words for me that is three minutes and
40 seconds long
uh the newspaper article uh of course
has no sound to it has only 19 new words
16 of them are new to me so uh you know
we can choose to look at whichever one
let's look at the uh the one we brought
in from the radio station
and here we have a sound bar because
this is has sound we can listen to the
sound
now there's some detailed instructions
on what to do with this which i don't
normally need anymore
so just quickly uh i will in the next
video talk about how i use this page but
you'll notice some of the other things
76 new words for me
here are a list of all the words that i
have previously saved
and that i'm trying to learn that are in
this now i'm gonna add to these by going
after some of the uh blue words which
are new words
so i think i'm gonna stop there so i
don't
run over my time
and then in the second uh video i'm
going to talk about what i actually do
with these texts so bear with me while i
shut this down